[Musique]
les appellations d'origine protégé ou
contrôlé ont été créé il y a plus de 70
ans le but à l'époque être gage de
qualité pour le consommateur et défendre
un terroir certains viuron critiqu cette
labellisation considérée comme trop
rigide pas assez moderne les AOP
connaissent une certaine défiance des
vigurons en sorte quand d'autres
souhaitent les faire évoluer de
l'intérieur
[Musique]
on prend tout ce qui est vert et doré et
on prend le bon pourri pour ceux qui qui
vienent d'arriver n'hésitez pas à
arracher les feuilles les pour bien
voir je vais essayer de trouver des
exemples mais ça typiquement vous pouvez
le mettre dans votre sa quoi voyez c'est
il y a pas de moisissure ça sent ça sent
pas mauvais s pas le vinaigre et c'est
surtout pas orangé en fait jour de
vendange à noiset sur les terres des
frères comes à 7ette heure les sécateurs
travaillent déjà à la fraîche là c'est
vraiment une jolie une jolie vendange en
perspective on a une proportion de 15 %
10 % de de raisin
passeriller il risque d'y avoir un super
potentiel de
[Musique]
qualité chacun un peu plus de 8 hectares
de vigne sur l'appellation vousouvra et
ce matin justement Florent récolte sa
parcelle la plus
prestigieuse ici on est sur le liodi qui
s'appelle le clour rompu donc c'est une
parcelle que je vunifie à part donc ça
veut dire que je ne je neassemble pas
avec d'autres
parcelles on est sur un super terroir
donc on est sur des pentes exposées
plein
sud on est sur des sols argil à Lex et
donc il y a une parcelle qui se divise
en deux une plus vieille et là c'est la
partie la plus jeune quoi donc dans la
plus vieille elle a à peu près 70 ans on
va pas avoir beaucoup de rendement des
rendements très faibles mais par contre
on va avoir des belles concentrations de
de de raisin et de
[Musique]
jus pour faire du moelleu là on va tout
prendre tu peux tu peux le goûter he
c'est réellement c'est ça peut répugner
mais mais en fait ça a vraiment des
saveurs nos vignerons ne sont pas des
néophyes ils forment déjà la 5e
génération de com à cultivé la vigne à
noiset sur l'aire d'appellation vousvrai
et pour eux afficher le label AOP
vousvrai sur leur étiquette c'est un peu
perpétuer la tradition nous il fallait
qu'on se fasse un prénom que ça soit
Mathieu comme moi donc Mathieu après la
suite de mon père pour se faire un
prénom
euh d'être sous un nom d'appel à tion
c'est quand même hyper porteur pour
commencer une fois en haut vous vous
remontrez sur ce rang là juste derrière
Philippe à l'aider à
finir le cahier des charges des AOP
évolue régulièrement mais à la marge
avec le réchauffement climatique les
vignerons savent déjà qu'il faudra faire
des changements plus importants à
l'époque de no nos parents ils vont
danger sous la neige des fois où il
faisait froid au mois
d'octobre maintenant vendange dans la
première quinzaine de septembre on
vendange que le matin parce qu'il fait
très chaud on est obligé d'acheter des
groupes de froid pour refroidir les jus
c'était des choses qui était impensable
à l'époque ne serait-ce qu'il y a 30 ou
20 ans 30 ans 40 ans donc on sait que
les choses évoluent très vite donc le
les vins ont changé avant c'est pareil
les vins avaient moins
d'alcool la la consommation a changé
aussi les gens buvaient plus mais
avec comment dire des vins moins chargés
en alcool et maintenant la on s'est
adapté aussi à une certaine
consommation on pourrait croire que les
appellations plus connues sont parfois
plus difficiles à faire évoluer et
pourtant à re petite appellation du
Berry Guillaume sorb a décidé de faire
fi des
AOP il existe des grosses cuves de
décuvage presque automatique mais dans
tous les cas il faut la pâte les
vendanges sont terminé et c'est au chet
que le travail se concentre après une
première fermentation les grappes de pin
noir sont envoyé au pressoir et le
décuvage se fait à la
main ça c'est une grape entière c'est
une grappe entière qu'on va écraser
maintenant avec un
jus qui pas encore très
coloré
Guillaume a perdu 30 % de sa récolte à
cause de la tempête qui a détruit tout
le vigob de pre mais malgré ça cétait
les bonnes vendanges avec une année
encore une fois très particulière on n
pas eu de on a eu des marqueurs de
chaleur on a eu pas mal d'humidité même
dans d'autres régions le mou a détruit
toute la récolte nous on s'en sort très
bien la spécialité de Guillaume c'est
qu'il a commencé à planter lui-même une
partie de ses vignes il y a plus 20
ans alors là on est sur une parcelle de
pinoc gris sur des sols donc là on a des
sables rouges des graves sur le dessus
du côeau et on part sur les argiles au
calcaair à la cassure c'est pour ça que
j'avais implanté des pinoc gris sur sur
cette
parcelleel qui est plus propice
finalement à ces pages là alors que à
côté on va être sur des sur des
sauvignons des Pinot
noirs fier de son terroir le bérichon a
affiché là au pi et qu'ainsi sur ces
bouteilles pendant 9 ans jusqu'en 2018
l'élément déclencheur en fait je pense
que c'est les premiers vins qui ont été
dégustés qui n'étaient pas dans la
typicité de l'appellation qui font que
derrière il y a ce qu'ils appellent un
contrôle de de suivi ça c'est tout à
fait logique il y a aucun problème
là-dessus mais le contrôle de suivi
finalement on entraîne encore un autre
et puis
après ça s'est intensifié sans avoir par
contre de justificatif et donc 17
contrôles en 9 ans ça m'a paru un petit
peu aberrant euh et donc en 2018 trois
contrôles en 3 jours on j'ai dit stop le
cahier des charges de tout AOP détaille
les règles de plantation des parcelles
type de sépage écartement entre les
pieds mais il régit aussi la méthode de
vinification c'est d'ailleurs souvent au
cours de la dégustation de contrôle que
les cuvés peuvent être
déclassés il y avait réellement un
problème de typicité ça ça j'en conviens
parfaitement mais euh en fait si tous
les vins doivent se ressembler faut plus
parler terroir même dans une petite
appellation il peut y avoir des
différences et je pense que c'est ça
aussi qui est intéressant quand on va
faire du parcellaire il doit y avoir une
différence entre la cuvé d'assemblage et
la cuvé de parcellaire et ben moi je
faisais du
[Musique]
parcellaire laoc est censé être un cadre
et tant mieux c'est un cadre pour pas
pour pas dévier c'est bien d'avoir un
cadre Ino ça c'est parfait après par
contre Ben parfois il y a il y a un
manque de compétence locale qui est qui
est flagrant il y a un manque de de de
volonté de prendre des risques pour
avancer donc en fait on stagne sur des
choses qui sont écrites depuis 70 ans
c'est peut-être un petit peu
dommage dans la Nièvre juste en face de
senser matthie cost élève des vins sur
l'ire d'appellation coteau du giénois
depuis
2008 l'intérieur a été désinfecté pour
l'année
prochaine
bon et ils seront bon pour les
poochaines
vendanges dès son installation ses cuvés
de blanc ont été déclassé et 10 ans plus
tard ces rouges ont perdu aussi leur
AOP en terme d'avertissement j'ai payé
des amendes alors voilà quelques
quelques amendes ce qui m'a fait dire au
bout d'un moment que mon expression de
vin ne correspondait pas à la vision de
l'ensemble de l'AOP par les opérateur
donc très tranquillement je me suis
retiré de l'appellation ça a été quand
même une bataille au début on vous a dit
non vous vous en faites pas parti et
puis au fin on peut être vexé au départ
puisque on estime être dans son bon
droit faire le plus naturellement
possible or on s'aperçoit qu'à la
dégustation la différence est trop
grande entre la typicité attendue des
vins dans le cadre de l'appellation et
l'expression des vins en étant le plus
naturel
possible Mathieu est fier désormais de
produire des vins de France une
appellation européenne qui regroupe tout
vin fabriqué en France sans appellation
spécifique voilà k moi je vais te faire
goûter un un sauvignon de la maison
c'est un sauvignon qui a été vénifié un
petit peu différemment de de mes voisins
puisque j'ai vénifié ce vin là comme
rouge voilà parce que kevin est un jeune
vigneron qui se lance dans le métier il
fait les vendanges chez des collègues
plus aguéris pour apprendre les
techniques
ouis on est sur une macération
pelliculaire on sent la peau du raisin
au goût exactement on s'est rendu compte
au final que le consommateur il en a pas
grandchose à faire ce qu'il veut c'est
boire quelque chose de bon et si ça
rentre pas dans un C des charges et ben
tant pis parce que derrière il y a des
personnes qui souhaitent boire ce genre
de vin et je pense que la dynamique à
l'avenir ben ça sera surtout le goût le
vigneron ou la vigneron la personne qui
fait ce vent là et désormais on se
renseigne plus de comment le vigniron ou
la vigiron travaille plutôt que si c'est
une appellation ou pas une appellation
ouais on peut y aller sur
celle-là le consommateur AG guéri aime
savoir comment le vigneron ou la
vigneronne travaille et c'est souvent
plus important qu'un label mais pour le
grand public laop compte beaucoup on est
quand même dans un monde de producteur
donc on fabrique des vins on va dire à
nos images donc on on y met aussi un peu
notre fierté on y met nos trip et il est
normal qu'à un moment donné quand on
quand on critique un système les gens se
sentent heurté parce qu'ils ont
l'impression d'être critiqués eux-mêm or
c'est pas du tout le cas nous ce qu'on
veut en tant que producteur de vin
nature c'est pourquoi pas par les
dégustations par l'échange pouvoir être
entendu et et améliorer ce
système grande ou petite les
appellations doivent évoluer au moins
pour sa adapté au changement climatique
avec la vague des néo vignerons adeptes
de 20 Natur les AOP ont parfois perdu
leur pouvoir d'attraction mais côté
consommateur le label reste un guide
efficace garant d'une
typicité